hi my name is before i play becca on pen
15.
my name is uh dylan gage and i play gabe
on pin 15. hi
i'm maya erskine and i play maya ishii
peters on pen 15.
and i'm anna konkel and i play anna cone
on pen 15. and we're gonna take
a buzzfeed quiz to see i guess how well
we know millennial versus gen z slang i
don't know either
at all really i thought we were
something else what do you mean a
different generation oh i knew we were
millennials but i just
no that's not what i meant listen i know
we're millennials i'm saying
the words that i've seen already under
millennials i thought were
belonging to gen z i don't know do this
millennial bae a word short for newborn
baby
a term meaning for sure an acronym uh
for before anyone else or a school
crush i think it's before anyone else
that was the only one that makes sense
but i'm bad that that's the one that
it's gonna be oh you were right
great you were right yeah
why isn't it just like short for baby
that's what i always thought it was
what'd you think it was i thought it
meant like my bae like my
my boo my guy that's what i thought too
but
you can call anyone bae can you use bae
in a sentence
like you're my bae like you come before
it right give me a definition
wow we're gonna suck at this anna i
don't
we don't even know millennial words
generation z
i need no idea okay okay a very
stressful situation
a tick tock dance challenge a term used
to describe something
that's super obvious another word for
fancy
i feel like another word for fantastic i
agree i'm between that and a very
stressful situation
but hi let's just think about like high
key this is high
this is high key or like that's high key
she's high key
definitely that's high key so meaning
fancy
you're going with fantastic high key
we're trying to think about it like
someone who's
really stressed out she's really high
key like that's what i think of it's
like
high notes like that is like
i would think stressful situation have
you ever used this word
um i've used a variant of it
low-key yeah so high key is fancy
it's fancy oh it's wrong you let us down
the wrong
path i literally didn't wow okay it
turned people down
something that's super obvious
that doesn't make sense like if you
low-key one
something you're like i want that but
just like a little bit you know not a
lot
like i don't like all right right right
we just hide he lost that you know what
that works
millennial gucci fashionable a way of
saying goodbye
sexy or good it cannot be a
way of saying goodbye in no way and i
don't think
is on the table i think it's good you
look pretty
gucci today i think good work
correct look at that no i wasn't 100
sure i thought
it was good okay
a really really really great song
another word for sex
an overachiever a word used to end a
discussion
i really like that last one that was to
be like
bop that means you gotta shut up okay i
wanna say something
i feel like that is what it is i think
so
it'd be really old-timey to say it's a
really really great song because that's
like bebop
it's a bop you know like no one's doing
that i'm gonna do
the word to you to a word used to end a
discussion ready
i agree my instincts
are wrong i wish you were correct
because that would
be a lot funnier than what it is that's
a bop
whip it bop it you know what i mean to
skip
it oh i think that's unrelated
millennial stan i know this one an
extreme
fan a suspicious man a word to describe
an
ultimate goal or a person who slides
into your dms it's gotta be an extreme
fan i know that one
k-pop stance i stan that means i support
or i'm a fan of them
yeah okay i stan my queen
the finn stuff a fake instagram account
different way to say fixing okay name
for your sister from another mister
faster than an instant
what does that feel like feels like
we're winning still
get to the next one millennial thirsty
hot person
in their 30s horny rude or ambitious
i i've heard people use thirsty in the
context of horny
he's thirsty you know i'm gonna place my
bet
on horny okay let's do it we are legends
we can't get these wrong i don't know
that one i found confusing also
so
simple someone who does way too much for
the person they like
the version of your crush you made on
sims a strategy used for getting someone
to date you
simp simple or someone who does way too
much for the person like a simpleton
i think it's shorter way of saying
simple i'm gonna go with that
it seems too obvious someone who does
way too much for the person they like
he's a sim he's this total sim the
version of your crush you made on sims
i'm
that should be eliminated right off the
bat i don't know
people do that who does way too much for
the person they like can we try that
sure yes okay so we need to go with anna
we need to go with anna to lead us
but also you can't do too much for a
woman that you like so just remember
that dylan
millennial dank okay something that's
not
bad someone who is rich a term to
describe something
cool a dark prank i've heard
the term dank weed i have this
what no that's the that's the only
context i've ever heard this word
i've heard someone say like that's dank
dank memes
and dank weed so it's also not a dark
prank i think it's something cool it's
got to be something cool
good job you guys gen z yeet to have sex
to buy something expensive to get drunk
to throw something
what's your instinct anna like what are
you drawn to
eat to eat yeah my instincts to get
drunk
are you gonna eat that i'm kind of
thinking to buy something expensive
all right let's do it no no he didn't
eat it over i can just imagine a bunch
of 13 year olds in the keep that over
the cafeteria being like yeah yeah so
last one y'all millennial
otp options an instagram filter
an acronym for one true pairing an
acronym for old timey people
white cloth flavor white cloth that's
the boomer juice
i don't even know what a white claw is
like monster energy drinks
old timey people or an acronym for one
true pairing
that could make sense i think that makes
sense they killed us
good job millennials why don't you just
use the word ship
my we got slang novice i hate to break
it to you but your knowledge of
millennial and gen z slang
is not lit fam you probably have to
google words on the daily but that's
okay
maybe your knowledge of gen x slang is
all that in a bag of chips i do know
what that means
yeah me too you're dylan we're slaying
geniuses
slang genius the vibes here are
immaculate you're totally fluent in old
things millennial and dempsey
your knowledge spans generations and
tbh i bet you even know a little gen x
slang
too nice job look at us though very
impressed
you guys feel a little jealous i'm not
jealous
check out pin 15 only on hulu what's the
term again symph
i'm saying you should be ascent yes
everyone out down
bow down now the f down
you